et pour en parler nous sommes avec à
benjamin amar enseignants porte parole
cgt du val de marne à ses côtés ou face
à face comme on préfère nicolas bailly
ce conseiller municipal de wingles ex
député ps du pas de calais bonsoir à
tous les deux merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors pas de
contrainte on nous dit emmanuel macron
mettra aucun professeur en danger
benjamin barès que vous êtes enfin un
enseignant rassuré ce soir
en aucun cas on obtient kg j'ai regardé
la petite mise en scène de l'après midi
bon je peux vous dire que moi je suis en
contact avec bon nombre d'enseignants du
fait de mes responsabilités syndicales
est d'abord avec ceux qui sont mes
collègues au lycée gutenberg de créteil
et honnêtement le leu leu l'état
d'esprit et moi d'aider des collègues
que j'ai c'est maintenant c'est plus
l'inquiétude et la colère c'est la
colère devant à la fois tant
d'amateurisme et en d'entêtement
je rappelle voilà actuellement les
autres foyers de clusters comparable à
la france ce que ça sert à rien de nous
comparer avec la norvège où il ya eu
vingt fois moins de cas mais par exemple
l'espagne l'italie l'état de new york
est bien là la rentrée elle est reportée
sine die et le reporter en septembre je
rappelle qu'il est à 60% des français
qui sont opposés effectivement à cette
rentrée le 11 mai à 59% des français qui
effectivement disent clairement qu'ils
ne remettront pas leurs enfants à
l'école donc on assiste à une véritable
mascarade à un entêtement finalement
emmanuel macron que ce soit à l'opinion
des français sur la réforme des
retraites où l'opinion des français sur
la santé publique pendant le creux vide
eh ben ils excusez-moi l'expression mais
ils s'en tamponnent allègre ment et il
va le payer politiquement ce qui est
clair et net c'est que nous à la cgt on
est en train d'organiser à la cgt
educ'action syndicats la campagne du
droit de retrait parce que la santé des
salariés la santé des enseignants la
santé des élèves
eh bien il n'y a pas de choses plus
importantes que ça et les aléas ma
chronique est finalement maintenant nous
indiffère nicolas bailly est votre
réaction
d'abord on j'apprécie la mesure des
propos de monsieur amar comme d'habitude
la cgt qui est le syndicat le plus
politique de france qui n'est d'ailleurs
pas un syndicat qui défend ni les
français ni les travailleurs mais qui
défend une ligne politique
révolutionnaire qu'on connaît bien
moi ma réaction c'est que un moment le
pays devra de toute manière repartir et
je ne vois pas ce qu'ils nient chantier
ce qui sera différent d'un pays en
septembre par rapport à aujourd'hui déjà
monsieur amar c'est une fête nous seuls
l'italie a décidé de reporter sa entre
en septembre l'état de new york et
l'espagne n'ont pas encore tranché sur
la date de reprise donc vérifier vos
notes
le l'allemagne reprend l'école le
catelet l'allemagne est un cluster à peu
près similaire similaire à la france la
chine réouvre ses écoles dans la
province de one qui est le endroit
d'origine de l'épidémie moi ce que
j'attendrais de la part de la cgt c'est
aussi des propositions parce que ce que
vous proposez aujourd'hui c'était juste
de reporter la rentrée en septembre
sans expliquer comment vous vous
envisagerez de faire cette rentrée et
comment vous protégerez au mieux les
enseignants et les enfants
les mesures qui sont prises aujourd'hui
sont les mesures qui sont quand même
issu de concertation sur des mesures
progressives
à un moment le pays ne peut pas rester à
l'arrêt jusqu'en septembre quand ses
voisins européens relance notamment
leurs économies et leurs écoles
c'est à la fois on dangereux pour la
stabilité du pays mais c'est aussi
dangereux pour le décrochage scolaire de
beaucoup d'enfants qui aujourd'hui je
parle avec beaucoup d'enseignants qui
aujourd'hui sont complètement au
décrochage et n'ont plus aucun lien avec
l'école
benjamin maaf vous le voulez bien on va
justement regarder en cette infographie
qu'on a déjà découvertes tout à l'heure
ce protocole sanitaire 63 pages on les a
évidemment pas tout résumer ici quatre
mètres carrés pour les enfants mais ce
qu obligatoire pour les enseignants
distance d'un mètre
ça ne vous rassure pas vous trouvez ça
court ou tout simplement non applicable
le benjamin a marre
non mais alors bon d'abord effectivement
la question qui se pose c'est la
question des moyens c'est-à-dire l'accès
aux masques gratuits ainsi possible
merci bien
parce que s'il s'agit là en l'occurrence
de personnels qui vont travailler
le l'accès aux tests sérologiques voilà
tout simplement
mais je voudrais réagir aux propos de
monsieur j'adore d'abord recevoir des
conseils de défense des travailleurs de
la part d'un socialiste renégats ça me
plaît énormément
ensuite je suis désolé mais les
déclarations du gouvernement espagnol
sont créés vont clairement dans le sens
d'un report de la rentrée et il en va de
même dans l'état de new york qui on se
donne rendez-vous lorsque les décisions
tomberont ensuite
excusez moi mais le laquelle la cgt est
là monsieur visiblement stevo qui
devrait aller regarder vos notes
la cgt elle est force de proposition et
la sortie énormément de documents
d'ailleurs philippe martinez est en lien
permanent avec le gouvernement et le
gouvernement connaît très bien nos
conditions bien évidemment qu'il faut
reprendre le boulot
bien évidemment que la reprise de
l'activité économique est crucial mais
ya quelque chose au dessus c'est la
santé des gens on n'envoie pas les gens
au casse-pipe voyez vous donc
et c'est là que je me permets de vous
arrêter parce que emmanuel macron
aujourd'hui dit clairement mettra aucun
professeur en danger les enseignants
souhaitent souci le souhaitent peuvent
ne pas reprendre le travail y compris
pour les mères qui voit là ne fait pas
organisé donc quand même ya une marge de
manoeuvre assez grande proposé par le
chef de l'état aujourd'hui attendu non
nantes run et ne tenait pas la confusion
l'association j'aurais fait quelle game
et makro êtes pas obligé de la marche 1
non mais c'est moi vous n'avez pas
interrompu monsieur vous n'avez pas tout
monsieur laissez moi tu es un militant
gay et leur donnera la parole
effectivement nicolas d'alice qui vous
répondra voilà merci bien laisser les
noix répondent de manière oui merci
en l'occurrence museler vous répondent
madame en l'occurrence en reprenant tel
quel à tarbes du moment là c'est très
étonnant
dc emmanuel macron veut clarifier les
choses mais pourquoi est-ce qu'ils ne
reporte pas la rentrée tout bonnement en
l'occurrence vous savez quoi
le nombre de journées qui vont
effectivement être effective pour les
élèves va être ridicule
1 on le sait très bien la rentrée
scolaire
l'année scolaire elle est foutue elle et
sa beauté savait dès le son de mon
interlocuteur sur le décrochage scolaire
la bonne blague
moi comme mes collègues on est rentré
dans l'éducation nationale pour lutter
contre les inégalités scolaires
ça va pas se jouer au mois de juin voyez
vous ça y est c'est clair l'année elle
est complètement
particulière la situation est totalement
particulière tout comme l'activité
économique on est dans une situation
exceptionnelle
il ya encore énormément d'incertitudes
donc voilà la rentrée scolaire on règle
le droid le sujet l'opinion
eric ultra-majoritairement effectivement
pour le report en septembre et en
septembre on reprendra une activité
scolaire normal qu'est ce que c'est et
puis qu'est ce que c'est que toute cette
discussion sur la sécurité juridique
qu'est ce que c'est que ça est en
direction d'un décès pardonnez-moi
nicolas bailly ce vous répondrai après
on passera à tence faire de votre échec
ne vous tombe pas dessus
benjamin marque ça serait dommage à côté
de vous voilà nicolas balises peut-être
que vous pourriez répondre effectivement
la langue des argumentations de benjamin
elma j'apprécie les talents de
visionnaire de monsieur amar qui nous
dit qu'ils en septembre la rentrée se
passera bien l'asp en cela le coc vider
le commis 19 sera encore en septembre et
on fait quoi en septembre aujourd'hui
toutes les mesures qui ont été prises
par leurs commandes par le gouvernement
sur les recommandations de scientifiques
permettent justement d'appréhender au
mieux cette rentrée de manière très
progressive très concertée et monsieur
sachez que les enseignants par exemple
qui ont des problèmes de santé qui sont
des personnes à risque ont déjà été
contactés pour pour ne pas retourner à
l'école et il ya la base du volontariat
qui a été rappelé par le présent n'est
qu'aujourd'hui base du volontariat à la
fois pour les enseignants et pour les
collectivités
parce qu'il faut rappeler ce qu'a
rappelé à mes anciens collègues juste
avant dans l'émission que le problème
est duale si vous avez d'un côté
l'éducation nationale qui gère les corps
enseignant et vous avez des
collectivités locales qui gèrent les
locaux dans lesquels ont lieu les cours
les recommandations du gouvernement de 4
mètres carrés pas élèves peuvent être
appliqués dans les écoles comme ma ville
à lens et ne peuvent pas être impliqué
dans certaines écoles qui sont d'un
modèle plus ancien ou qui n'ont pas la
même place donc ça sera de toute manière
au cas par cas dans la dentelle de
s'asseoir mais où en septembre
kovy 19 salles en septembre et les tests
sérologiques me chammas aujourd'hui on
sait très bien que les tests
sérologiques n'ont aucune valeur parce
que moi qui ai eu que 8 19 et comme vous
et je suis content que vous employez
sortie pour qu'on puisse en débattre ce
soir on a eu que 8 19 on peut pas nous
dire aujourd'hui si on ne peut pas leur
ai attrapé ou non et on l'état
sérologique
aujourd'hui sont inopérantes tandis
qu'au test pour savoir si les gens sont
malades ou pas ils n'ont la valeur comme
on le teste et réaliser un quart d'heure
après vous rencontrez des gens dans la
rue peut-être n'a déjà plus de valeur
ces tests ces tests pour tester les
personnes ne sont intéressants que quand
vous tester des malades que vous pouvez
après isolé mais tu espères des
personnes négatif vous serez incapable
de tester 67 millions de français tous
les jours
l'allemagne avait commencé des campagnes
massives de test et aujourd'hui elle
revient en arrière sur cette stratégie
de campagne massive parce qu'elle se
rend compte que c'est inutile c'est
inefficients là ce que les cinq
campagnes de tests efficience et de
tester des personnes qui présentent des
premiers symptômes du comique pour les
isoler et à la fois isolé leurs proches
et benjamin amar la réponse non mais
attendez c'est formidable c'est à dire
que dans la macro nyon nous a expliqué
il ya trois mois que les masses ça ne
servait à rien sous toutes les coutures
pour finalement nous dire bah finalement
si les mains c'est vachement important
on a vu qu'on avait bien compris à
l'époque l'argumentaire sur les masques
il était conditionnée par la
disponibilité en masse et donc
maintenant ce sont les tests qui ne
servent à rien je rappelle que si
l'allemagne cherche juste à ce qu'on
attendait monsieur je ne vous ai pas
couper la parole d'accor donc je vous ai
laissé ressortir votre litanie pourquoi
donc en l'occurrence maintenance et les
tests qui ne servent à rien c'est tout à
fait nouveau et vous savez monsieur on
devrait vous invitez je pense dans les
séminaires scientifiques ou au conseil
scientifique
parce que vous savez vous avez plein de
certitudes moi j'aimerais vous dire
effectivement j'ai attrapé le coc vite
comme vous et lorsque j'ai discuté y
compris avec les médecins qui m'ont
soigné
j'ai bien compris et c'est toujours le
cas quand on regarde aujourd'hui les
informations et qu'on écoute
effectivement les spécialistes qu'il ya
bien plus d'incertitudes que de
certitudes
donc là vous êtes très a certes hâtif
vous êtes très péremptoire sur la
question des tests et c'est très
étonnant
et je vais vous dire la seule vérité
effectivement qu'on peut dire aux
français aujourd'hui c'est qu'il ya
plein d'éléments qu'on ne connaît pas
s'ils pouvaient entre qui pouvait
évoquer la maladie de kawasaki ya encore
quinze jours
donc effectivement vous avez dit mais en
septembre le virus il sera là oui mais
on se laisse en l'occurrence un petit
peu de temps pour justement ce enfin
proposer des critères de santé publique
aux français qui tiennent la route sur
les masques parce que sur le nez masque
là aussi c'est la complète incertitude
on nous disait il n'ya pas de masque
la grande distribution nous explique
qu'elle restaure monstrueux alors que
c'était la pénurie encore il ya quinze
jours donc les français n'y comprennent
rien et encore une fois sur la question
des transports sur la question de
l'école sur la question de la sécurité
dans l'entreprise
on a des tas de choses à mettre en place
et il faut du temps l'école le lui la
lutte contre le décrochage scolaire je
le dis et je le répète c'est la raison
une des raisons qui m'ont poussé à
devenir enseignant bon sang de bonsoir
c'est pas sur le mois de mai et sur le
mois de juin
tendant à l'est un mois et demi de cours
que ça va se jouer en ayant battu marc
jordan et moi on va là c'est aussi
répondre nicolas bailly le président
brouille deux mois fin d'école vous êtes
enseignant vous le savez deux mois sans
école ça peut être aussi traumatisant
pour certains enfants pour qui c'est
compliqué de faire des devoirs toute la
journée
voilà qui est parent c'est ça qu'est ce
que vous rêvez
pardon mais je réponds une chose très
simple madame
encore une fois je répète je lis
excusez-moi j'ai été à l'hôpital
j'ai été au service de réanimation
madame je sais ce que c'est la forme
grave du code vide c'est une peste
d'accord alors moi je dis ah ça c'est
vous c'est quoi
oui c'est vrai deux mois sans épaules
cette problématique halléguen service de
réanimation pour ce pour cette paix est
là c'est bien plus grave
donc encore une fois la santé publique
c'est ce qui compte le plus est ce que
vous ne dites pas quand même et je suis
très étonné le monde
si effectivement derrière il n'y avait
pas un lien entre les pressions
patronales pour la reprise de l'activité
économique
et cette obsession sur l'école ça c'est
très étonnant mais personne n'est dupe
alors les patrons enfin l'économie des
français en général est peut-être voilà
tout le monde devra payer un moment
donné nicolas bailly selon le mot de la
fin la réponse à benjamin a marre
monsieur mois pour être issu d'une
famille d'enseignants pour avoir
enseigné aussi moi même pendant quelques
années et pour avoir encore beaucoup
d'enseignants a fallu j'ai beaucoup de
gens ma famille qui enseigne aujourd'hui
à des enfants de personnel hospitalier
ad
enfants qui ne peuvent pas faire
autrement qu'elle est calé à l'école des
écoles tourner dans notre pays il faut
qu'on trouve des solutions ensemble
moi je suis partisan de l'unité
nationale face à cette maladie qui est
je le sais une maladie horrible terrible
qui malheureusement ne sera pas de
circuler dans les deux années qui
viennent et qu'il faudra apprendre à
vivre avec prendre des mesures avec
canto quant au patron et la pression
patronale de toute manière l'économie
reprendra que les écoles on ne
reprennent pas aidé incombera
malheureusement en france est de gérer
leurs enfants chez eux
le chômage partiel sont pas tarder à les
démonter monsieur la sécurité oui ben la
sécurité au travail des entreprises dans
ma circonscription qui nous rendait bien
aucun problème qui tourne à 100 % de
leurs salariés mais pour que lui a passé
par porto merci benjamin hammam merci
également à nicolas bailly est d'avoir
joué le jeu de ce débat merci d'avoir
été en direct avec vous sur rt france